Joe doesn't need to underplay himself I
was reading that article that the ringer
did about you yeah and they talked about
how you met your wife and then she was a
reporter total stalk job right and then
you were just like hey tell the reporter
down there that Joe Buck wants to talk
to her yeah and she got the message
no he set it down and said tell him
someone wants to talk to me I hope it's
not Jill and the guy that go-between so
why would you say that she goes you know
I don't know I've never heard anything
bad about him he just looks like a smug
arrogant jerk yeah yeah why do you think
that about you that became a metaphor
for your career I mean that's kind of
what I deal with yeah that's why I wrote
a friggin book right like here I'm not
the smug arrogant jerk that you think I
am it's why I called a lucky bastard I
am I am a lucky bastard but why do
people think that I I think because of
my style on TV and I do baseball and
every baseball fan wants to hear their
hometown guys and I'm the national guy
and so they get pissed no matter what
you say and then I guess my style comes
off like I I think bigger or better than
the game it's actually the other way
around I try to talk get out of the way
and let the game go I never got the
impression like the only pronounced ally
as a Yankee fan
I always thought Joe Morgan didn't like
the Yankees and then someone's like yeah
because the Big Red Machine there's like
that the late nineties are being
compared to that but that's the only
time I ever felt that I never got the
impression that you were in New York
Yankees I did a thing for Funny or Die
on that where people are MF and me
everywhere I go
and that just kind of that's they're not
unique Kansas City thinks the same thing
in San Francisco because you're used to
hearing guys openly rooting on air for
your team
my manager Jonathan Sam and I were in LA
for the World Series and I managed a big
Cubs fan and whenever you would talk
you'd be like he hates the Cubs yeah
especially when the Cubs were down by
the way when it comes we're down he'd be
like Oh Joe [ __ ] buckets he's talking
about the hey listen he's not talking
about the Cubs enthusiastic his wife
would just try to be nice I go yeah he's
bias yeah well I think maybe I could be
wrong the bias is in the ear of the
listener more than it is nice I mean
come on if you just take it on face
value as an announcer I'm the only one
to ever call them winning the World
Series in the history of television
there's there's a little bit uh you know
I could be accused of going the other
way on that so he's wrong telling me -
is he your manager he's my my comedy
manager yeah he sucks it's so
interesting that I feel like you know
reading the book and reading about you
like the the criticisms and the stuff
people say about you like they have a
pretty deep affect on you like it seems
like it hits you uh yeah I think it's
death by a thousand cuts you know once
you get it enough you know but but
here's the thing in-person people are
great even in New York to go you hate
the Yankees no I don't okay what shot
you drinking then they'll buy you a shot
and you know I think you kind of get
looked at as a as a thing and it's like
kill the messenger like you just said
when the Cubs aren't playing well
they're down three to one
I sound like I hate the Cubs cuz I'm
screamin and Yellin for the Indians but
but then they get mad cuz I turn around
and start screaming for the Cubs when
they come back in the series so yeah I
think I'm too thin-skinned and I'm
trying to get better at that I go to
therapy for that you do hell yeah is
that when do you go not enough we want
now like once every three weeks four
weeks does really help you not to this
point no let me get you more yeah I walk
out of there I feel a little lighter I
feel a little more myself feel like the
old Joe the fighting Joe right and then
you know a couple tweets later and not
happy it is weird how like the negative
stuff on social there's a million
positive things but the one negative
thing they're validating what I already
knew I'm shitty exactly it's so it's so
it's like the highs and the lows too
cause it's so easy especially in the
business you're in I'm sure for somebody
to like really lift you up like you're
like the right person says that you did
a great job on this call like you're
through the through the roof but then
all you need is that one person right to
say the wrong thing and it's a total
stranger and your days ruins it makes no
sense yeah I mean if you think about it
yeah but I don't and
that's smart so I just kind of let it
hit